For many Japanese, these will be some of the strongest memories...
...of an emperor now preparing to end his reign.
In 2011, Akihito and Empress Michiko were in the forefront...
...as the country struggled to recover...
...from the devastating earthquake, tsunami and nuclear disaster,...
...appealing to their people's strength and compassion.
As a boy, Akihito lived through the Second World War,...
...being prepared for a role widely seen as divine.
After the nuclear attacks on Hiroshima and Nagasaki,...
...his father, Emperor Hirohito, persuaded his ministers and generals to surrender...
...and, under a US written constitution,...
...would renounce any claims to imperial divinity and all political power.
As crowned Prince, Akihito dispensed with a thousand-year-old tradition...
...by marrying a commoner.
Succeeding to the throne in 1989,...
...he continued Hirohito's role of figurehead over Japan...
...transformed by its economic rise.